bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors d'abord sur la forme
on s'attend à quoi avec une personnalité
comme jean castex on appelle qui va
s'exprimer tout à l'heure devant
l'assemblée nationale
on s'attend à quelque chose
d'extrêmement contrôler et probablement
de 2,2 très construit également pour une
une première un premier discours de
politique générale ensuite quelque chose
d'encadrer parlée par les propos du chef
de l'état donc qu'il va y avoir un volet
sanitaire
un volet économique un volet écologique
vous aurez noté l'immense absence de
tout le volet sécuritaire
on a eu un président de la république
qui le 14 juillet s'expriment pendant
1h15 et ne mentionne pas les armes et ne
mentionne pas les opérations extérieures
ne mentionne pas le meurtre l'assassinât
atroce du du chauffeur de bus de bayonne
qui ne mentionne pas mélanie lemay qui a
été fauché par un délinquant
multirécidiviste donc il ya tout un pan
de la politique et des préoccupations
des français qui n'ont pas été abordés
donc on attend du premier ministre
qu'ils comblent ce déficit est qu'il
montre que sur le volet sécuritaire sur
le volet militaire
il y à aussi démesurée que la politique
générale ne se limitera pas à port du
masque à partir du 1er août des mesures
de soutien plus ou moins efficace
d'ailleurs pour les entreprises et puis
de l'accompagnement écologique pour la
rénovation des des foyers ont ça veut
dire que vous attendez un peu mieux de
jean castex que des manuels battront
vous n'avez pas été convaincu par son
discours ya alors je pense que au delà
de moins je pense que les français n'ont
pas été n'ont pas été convaincus le
discours était long il était laborieux
le président avait donné l'image en 2010
celle d'un président
fructifonds on a un président totalement
évanescent il y a une toute petite note
en fin d'interview sur le rapport du
défenseur des droits un moment où les
dom à ria n'entre que ce défenseur des
droits a été jacques toubon sous
influence notamment du cran notamment du
ccf dans des influences racialiste
islamistes on a de vrais questionnements
qui pèsent sur l'indépendance de la
justice
on a de vrais questionnements qui pèsent
sur la nomination de ce garde des sceaux
qui est surnommé aquitator donc vous
voyez que les français ont raison de se
poser des questions parce que finalement
on a l'impression que la présidence de
la république qui était censé prendre
acte des échecs des années passées
poursuit sur sa lancée et évitent pour
le coup là évite vraiment ça n'apparaît
pas du tout dans le discours du chef de
l'état
tout un pan de la politique du du
légitime d'un chef d'état donc il ya une
réflexion à mon avis profonde pour le
nouveau chef du gouvernement à mener qui
consiste à dire est ce que je me
contente de m'inscrire dans les pas du
président de la république ou est-ce que
je m'assume en tant que premier ministre
et que j'embrasse la totalité de mes
prérogatives mais le fera ça s'assume et
est-ce que c'est pas un peu le rôle du
premier ministre justement de s'inscrire
dans le travail du président le premier
ministre par la constitution et la
deuxième tête de l'exécutif le président
de la république est censé donner des
directions pour la politique générale
mais ensuite la mise en oeuvre est censé
appartenir pleinement au premier
ministre on a bien compris que cette
figure bureaucratique effacés élu local
était utile à emmanuel macron en
prévision de 2022
mais il va aussi falloir compter avec la
volonté des hommes
on sait très bien qu'un homme ce n'est
pas un jouet ce premier ministre là
pourrait se révéler avoir un caractère
beaucoup plus trempé que ce qu'a pu
anticiper
emmanuel macron et c'est l'occasion de
le montrer et
s'affirmer donc selon vous les y aura
forcément une inflexion par rapport en
tout cas la politique des doors philippe
alors s'il n'ya pas d'un cil n'y a pas
d'inflexion il y a à ce moment la crise
politique et c'est le le vrai défi pour
emmanuel macron qui a annoncé hier qu'il
n'y avait pas de changement de cap ce
qui est un vrai problème ce faire que
les français qui ont entendu le
président de la république parlait d'une
réinvention non seulement de la nation
de la société elle même mais de lui en
tant que président de la république un
jet j'ai besoin de me réinventer at il
dit à plusieurs reprises cette
réinvention suppose un changement de cap
hier il affirme qu'il n'y a pas de
changement de cap donc il n'ya pas de
réinvention
si en plus de ça le premier ministre n'a
aucune latitude si en plus de ça il
n'est pas capable de mener une politique
qui lui est propre et qui n'est pas
capable de s'inscrire dans une ligne qui
diffère de celle de l'ancien premier
ministre vous avez entendu comme moi
hier la question de léa salamé vous
remplacer un premier ministre de 50 ans
énarque de droite élu local par un autre
président un premier ministre de 50 ans
énarque élu local le premier était
populaire le deuxième est inconnue en
quoi il ya un changement de cap
emmanuel macron était bien en peine de
répondre il va falloir que le premier
ministre incarne ce changement de cap
monsieur saint clair merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes politologue marty